hello  [Music]  I'm Not The Lovable bookstore manager in  New York or the shop clerk in LA or the  doting husband in the suburbs no not  anymore  allow me to introduce myself  I've gone through a bit of refinement  upon crossing the pond and living in  London has allowed me to bury the past  if you will gone are the days of  unrequited love  not this time around I'm focusing on  Academia and instruction while keeping  my typical extracurricular activities  strictly professional  almost made time to exchange ideas with  like-minded colleagues unfortunately  with friends in high places they usually  come others attempting to climb that  social ladder some may end up fun or  shall I say pushed to their social death  [Music]  the question is  my home  [Applause]  foreign  [Music]